didn't call you Derek Jackson yeah Derek
Jackson or like he compared me and then
he compared me to only fans model I was
just like his behavior on that first
go-round on round one was so abhorrent I
don't know I don't even know if I would
have had a second conversation with him
because it was so disrespectful yeah
well and I thought the lead attorney was
going to be on with me the second round
that's the thing for a third round like
discussion like what do we disagree on
like that's that's the problem I have is
like we're having a conversation and I'm
cool with that but like I don't even
really know what we're debating yeah
because that wasn't clear it just starts
to be like I don't like the way you do
entertainment I don't like the way like
the red pill doesn't like yeah you
should you should give advice like it's
just kind of you can't really debate
that his opinion how how you like
something that's yeah that's his opinion
yeah and so it's kind of just